if you don't think there's hope for the  world  while they're going on  seeing the world  you keep going for family  I'm not family no  your cargo  [Music]  why are you so important  Somewhere Out West they're working on a  cure I think what really impressed them  was the fact that I didn't turn into a  monster if she so much as twitches  it's okay  [Music]  if I'm taking you with me  do what I say when I say  get any advice on the best way west  yeah go  go you've come this far  and you know what's out there  you're not going to scare us  scared him  [Music]  never said any of us could have ever  imagined  be careful who you put your faith in my  my father  we're summons  [Music]  trust me